your outfit in a box your manhood
shipped direct it's a male Griffin if
you noticed
yeah it's rather obvious outfitter II a
German click and ship startup has agreed
to a rather dangerous challenge dress me
hip enough for the city's most famous
nightclub which outfit do i do first
let's do let's do casual first and then
we'll work up to work up to Bernheim
okay register online have a phone
consult with one of sixty stylists and
your personalized box will arrive 10
days later half of our customers are in
a relationship and harp may be our
signal so it's not about like getting a
girl but maybe as well about impressing
your girl you have it hope okay flush
with 13 million euros from Highland
Capital outfitter E is offering Berlin
cool in four countries the what man do
is they shop and bulks so when men
behave in Europe as we see so far but I
think is the same for America man that
boy yes even Italian man ah Italian are
a little bit special
each box arrives with a note from your
stylist and some stern German
instructions but with a twist
first open a beer so this is the first
outfit mmm looks good
tell me I mean I don't know it seems it
seems a little tight it seems like so I
think we could get the Chino one size
bigger it seems like I'm advertising a
little here yeah I think I think so too
it outfit cost 358 euros with the jacket
another 250 my next outfit would set me
back more than 500 euros but what I
don't like I can ship back free of
charge and things that aren't too tight
I'm not notice no the size is really
really good actually here's the box that
will put to the test total price 340
euros all right so this this is what's
gonna get me number times definitely
yeah she said right on the put on the
Hat yeah from a hat yeah it's gonna be
like my yes yeah and what we do is we
roll up these I basically look like
ideal crystal meth
for it like for a Berlin person right
now you need to look like a math hat or
anything you look just like yeah a lot
of guys here that's bird hind behind me
it's 6:30 the morning voice is still
going strong you can hear the music and
I'm gonna see if I can get in with this
out there we're going commando on the
camera it's concealed but as you can see
there's not much of a line victory
inside there's Romanesque decadence
after one beer I leave in triumph but
with a limp and not from the clubbing
those Doc Martens don't quite fit as you
can see I got in and I can be just as
confident that I'm never gonna wear this
outfit again Hans Nichols Bloomberg
Berlin